once I didn't come our car testing
Manuel Schaefer says the Golf GTI is the
quintessential compact sports car
naturally other manufacturers want to
compete in this segment as well a good
example is Kia's CGT in Germany the CGT
is available as a three-door or
five-door model the three-door model is
called pro c GT but both models come
with the same engine
health struck du Manoir says the Kia
Cee'd GT comes with a 1.6 liter turbo
engine with an output of 150 kilowatts
or 204 horsepower and you can really
feel that power when you step on the gas
the 1.6 liter direct-injection gasoline
engine has a newly developed twin-scroll
turbocharger this gets you from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in 7.6 seconds and
produces a top speed of 230 kilometers
per hour
the seat get a hot young man who says if
you hit this button with the GT logo on
the steering wheel
you'll hear sound of the exhaust changed
to a deep loud roar the button also
shows the rev on the left of the display
and turbocharger pressure on the right
it's supposed to change the throttle
response too but Amanda well can't
really tell the exact definition but
it's still plenty of fun to ride this
little race here along winding country
roads the cg tees exterior has a
distinctive sporty look the four-point
LED daytime running lights and Kia's
typical Tiger nose radiator grille and a
GTS design make it instantly
recognizable at the rear there's a dual
exhaust system and a chrome GT logo plus
a roof spoiler with a third brake light
the trunk has a capacity of between 380
and 1318 liters holding back the rear
seats gives you an almost flat surface
the interior has lots of buttons mainly
for the air conditioning
the gear knob looks similar to that of
the GTI and Recaro sports seats with a
GT logo are standard and back on the
road you can instantly tell what these
seats were designed for at high speeds
they support the passengers well without
cramping them
all GT versions like all seed models are
manufactured in salina in Slovakia at
Kia's European production site and like
every European Kia car this GT comes
with a seven-year warranty says the CGT
is really fun to drive even though it
can't quite keep up with the more
powerful golf GTI and similar cars but
the entry-level c GT is available for
just under twenty five thousand euros
that's five thousand euros less than the
golf GTI
I think Athene the c GT is available in
two equipment lines GT challenge and GT
track the latter comes with sin on
headlamps adaptive curve following front
lighting and a digital DAB radio this
upgrade cost 3000 euros and is well
worth considering